thank you for waiting on my
video for episode one of season two with
mandalorian it's it's november so i do
it now would have felt weird doing it in
october i was still in horror movie mode
you know you can't be out of season on
these things
also spoilers the only way i can talk
about this episode is with spoilers in
fact every episode of mandalorian i talk
about is gonna have spoilers but i'll
remind you
every time so season two of mando's hit
mando is back and
here's the premise here's the jizz mando
goes to tatooine get some help from not
boba fett on tatooine and he
needs to convince these two factions who
hate each other to work together that's
pretty that's it and i gotta say it was
a great
reintroduction to the world of the
mandalorian it was a great massaging us
back into that which is a galaxy far far
away but a very personal
one-person's pov look into that seedy
ass underworld so yeah our friend mando
gets word that there is a mandalorian on
tatooine which we were all like at least
i was i was like what
boba fett then you see this dude this
boba fett boba fett
and you're like that is not boba fett it
looks like someone wearing their
brother's clothes that don't fit them
but they're doing it to make themselves
look cooler was what it looked like
clearly it wasn't boba fett but could
still be a mandalorian then dude tells
mando hey let's go have a drink which
i thought that was actually that could
be a very clever mandalorian litmus test
like if two mandalorians
meet and they don't know if they're
actually mandalorians one they could be
like hey the real mandalorian can be
like hey let's have a drink together
if the other one takes out their helmet
they can be like you're not a mando
you take that armor off right now turns
out the one who offered the drinks
takes off the helmet at first i was like
that's not pierce bros man that was
timothy only fun but i
still had young scream too timothy
oliphant in my mind
just dude looks like pierce brosnan-ish
but yeah amanda's not having it he's
like take that armor off right now
you're not actually a mandalorian and
basically there's this crate dragon
that's terrorizing this town so dude's
like look i'll give you this armor if
you just
help us defeat this thing because i love
the armor and the armor gave this guy
the opportunity to protect this town
he strolls up in town with his badass
mandalorian armor
after the empire fell and you know
there's that power vacuum and so
all these factions come in like hey we
own the town now so this dude with his
newly found mandalorian boba fett armor
is like
i'm gonna take these guys out and i'm
gonna protect the town but he does care
about the town i actually appreciate
that dude it's like i'll give you this
armor i love the armor
but i love the people of this town more
that was a cool moment for him because
not everyone would do that man like i
mean shoot i played star wars galaxy's
vanilla
it's hard to get armor that looks like
boba fett i'd be like i mean
people of this town are cool and all but
it took me a while to get this
come on that might be another reason i
like this episode is because when i
played star wars galaxies like
old school star wars galaxies otherwise
known as the star wars
grind among my friends and i i spent all
my time
at tatooine i just i was a bounty hunter
and that's where i role played i
rp there kind of wild the game had so
much to offer and i just
tatooine that was home so the people of
this town have to team up with tuscan
raiders who also want this crate dragon
dead
and so they're like hey we don't like
each other but it's one of those classic
enemy of my enemy kind of scenarios in
which i have to think
one of them on the tuscan side or the
town folk side were like wait a minute
i played breath of the wild once you get
this flight down it's pretty easy
someone had to have at least seen a
let's play but
that's pretty much the boss fight
they're trying to lure this crate dragon
out trying to blow it up from underneath
and
just thinking i thought it was isolated
to sands because like oh
mountain rock that's just too tough no i
can go up through the mountains too
things like josh gad and that shitty
artemis fowl movie but all that is to
say that
simple enjoyable premise of hey we have
a problem
mando needs to fix it he brings these
two boring factions together
to fight the bigger problem i just i
enjoyed it because that's what
mandalorian is you know it took me a
while in season one to really
come to grips with like what is because
you hear mandalorian you're like oh
there's mandalorian lore mandalorian and
jedi lauren
it really is this episodic point of view
of this one person traversing the post
civil war era of this galaxy far far
away but it's not galaxy scale you know
it feels smaller which that episodic
formula
isn't new to star wars clone wars series
we're talking
old school clone wars series with the
samurai jack animation
season one of that was very episodic but
it was still this large galactic war
going on so it felt bigger
mandalorian feel smaller more personal
when i accepted that i was like oh yeah
this show is fun granted season two
episode one says it's chapter nine
so it's supposed to feel like oh this
arc that goes up
and then to chapter eight this is the
next one chapter nine but it doesn't
feel like that to me because like
chapter seven
chapter eight moff gideon darksaber and
then chapter nine all right we're back
on tatooine and we're dealing with this
local problem which i'm totally fine
with i'm just saying it feels more like
season two episode one
than chapter nine as a whole this
episode does have a couple of member
berries which star wars is kind of known
for at this point the member berry
moments are boba fett's armor that's an
easy one you know it's boba fett's armor
so of course but that does play into the
end and that actually is really
intriguing stuff
the fact that the sheriff's speeder bike
is anakin's pod racer repurposed to be
his speeder bike i'm like what are the
odds of that r5 still has the damage on
his head from his bad motivator from
star wars a new hope i mean those easter
eggs and throwbacks are cool and all i
don't want the show to get
buried under them you know it already
has a compelling lead character and it's
already an interesting show i don't want
to feel like i'm tuning in to have
the showrunners inundate me with these
nostalgic moments to try to keep me on
the hook i'm already there that said
glad r5 isn't dead then in the end you
see the back of someone's head i'm like
holy [ __ ] it's tamara morrison and it is
which means
boba fett i don't know when boba fett's
going to resurface in this season it
could be at the end of the season it
could be
the next episode i don't know but dude
definitely has his eye on the
mandalorian and his boba fett so i just
have a feeling he's gonna find him and
that was the part where we theorize all
right so boba fett's helmet has that it
looks like a bullet being in it like
something point blank
shot him what are the odds boba fett has
amnesia
what are the odds what's the over under
what i'm 50 50 right now to be honest
with you because amnesia is just such a
thing
shows do also are we just going to
breeze over the fact that we saw boba
fett without his helmet
that's a pretty big deal i don't know it
was
like when i was growing up and all i had
was the original trilogy everyone was
theorizing like what's he look like and
then
after the prequels we knew that he would
look like django fat so so now we knew
but we didn't actually
see boba fett the guy actually without
his helmet i mean we saw him as a kid
without his helmet so now it's like i
saw adult boba fett without his helmet
for the first time on screen
ever it's like and it happened now i
guess that's
that all right cool all i know is i'm
glad boba fett is tamara morrison i'm
glad tamara morrison came back
for boba fett as simple as that is and
as logical as that is
i mean that does come down to whether or
not the actor wants to do it so i'm glad
he said yes i like the simple premise of
this
episode it was a good reintroduction to
the world of the mandalorian
bring on those baby yoda memes folks
most of all i like the message that
two sides that absolutely positively do
not like each other
can come together and work together
let's all keep that in mind after
tomorrow also known as
november 3rd i feel like the lesson of
this episode hitting this week was
a conscious effort very purposely done
all right so man delorean season two
episode one have you seen it what did
you think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
you